cal quattro is going to be the northeast
ohio ford dealer starting pitcher for
the tribe what a year he is having in
nine starts after an indian's loss he is
4-0
the team is six and three he has a 152
era and he has ended two three-game
losing streaks and two one-game losing
streaks so he's been the man you want on
the mound after a loss
and then was hitless in his next seven
and now he's got a base hit to begin
tonight
number
173 so he's five off the leader
and a double play ball
clemente chang on the miller hey indians
turn two
you know and you look at that's uh
quattro again goes out and makes his
pitch and he has now 17
ground ball double playouts that he is
made this year
swings and lifts it high in the air to
right playable for bradley zimmer
and a quick first inning for cal
quantrill indians coming to back and now
they'll see daniel lynch who faced
cleveland when he made his big league
debut
yeah that's quite a while ago and
they'll be surprised to see that he's a
much better pitcher now
and he takes down and in so lynch has
walked more hitters than
royals pitching did in the entire double
header yesterday
there's a line drive base hit right
field straw racing around third he's
gonna have to hold up though he had to
make sure that got over the head
of whit mirrorfield before he could
break and so now the bases are loaded
with nobody out
[Music]
and it is a strike over the inside edge
perfect location that is right there
reyes
you got to go
now chang's opportunity
wraps one into left field and a slip and
a misplay by ben and tendy that's gonna
clear the bases chang head down around
second on his way to third
he is safe
three nothing cleveland a good catch or
a triad so
he slipped no that's what happened went
down to one knee that's going to be a
triple for chang in a three base
clearing
triple
for you chang his uh third triple of the
year give him three rbis and the indians
will play from in front
and boy they make the walks now they
make a pay
[Music]
there's a good slider or at least one
that was tempting enough to get miller
to chase it
two down there it
is that's the teaser up just enough you
can see the
light rain
daniel lynch makes his 34th pitch he
strikes out three
but he gives up three on you chang's
triple and cleveland leads three nothing
now the 3-2
strike three call he took a fastball
and santana out looking three-nothing
tribe runners at the corners gets
another one
has had trouble getting it out of his
club they still turn to yes they don't
amazing job give a lot of credit in the
pivot to ernie clement who hung in there
waited for the feed from ramirez and
then quickly
got it on to first to end the inning
at bernie clement 216 batting average
couple of homers eight rbis
and now he drives one high in the air
deep left center field and go on a home
run
slow down ernie slow down
ernie clement
drives one up into the bleachers just
above the 19-foot wall and it's four to
nothing cleveland the indians with three
in the first and
one more in the second leading four to
nothing
he just stayed with the slider and puts
him away easily second strikeout for
cuatro one down sometimes you think of
the slider is the pitch that sweeps away
and that one just straight down
and now we're two down yucheng playing
his 81st game with the indians this year
and there's a called strike beltai
strike three and that is four strikeouts
for daniel lynch he does face the
minimum indians leading four nothing as
andrew ben and tendy leads things off
for kansas city
and a fastball came back over the inside
corner front door sinker how about that
locked him up third strikeout for
cuantre when you can make this pitch boy
it is a good night because that's a
perfect pitch a little two-seam fastball
or the running uh sinker look at them
just framing it right there
alberto mundesi waves at strike three a
couple of k's for quantrill in the
fourth
four nothing indians
but boy when you and that catcher get on
the same page it's a treat to watch it
yeah there's the two seamer he couldn't
hold it
daniel lynch
after 49 pitches in the first two
innings
he then made 31 pitches the next three
and here he is
giving the royals some length
and the pitch and a swing and a miss at
a good off speed offering got him to
reach for it
reyes strikes out and that is five of
them now for daniel lynch
here comes the 2-2 and a swing and a
liner caught by nikki lopez
a leaping grab on a backhand on a hot
shot off the bat of zimmer what a play
by nicki to end inning number six we'll
face adelberto monday who is one for two
he's been what you call a stopper the
old one game losing streak that's a
killer hunter's been red hot but over
two tonight nobody on two down top of
the seventh and a slider is hit well
down the left field line will it stay
fair it will and it's gone
another home run for red hot hunter
dozier it's his 15th home run of the
year and his fifth home run in his last
13 games and the royals are on the board
they're down 4-1
hitters are always the first to know
when they get it see that sets the bat
down goes on the into the trot pitchers
usually are the second look at the
launch angle and launch was way up way
up there his ball was called up on
september the 12th and he's now seven
for 22.
there you go bucket
closes them out
24th save of the year
cal cuatro the winner he goes to 7-3
as the indians even or they
a win tonight
[Music]
by a final score of four to one
and kansas city still leads the overall
series two games to one after they took
the doubleheader yesterday the finale
scheduled for tomorrow
weather permitting
indy is now 74 and 76 on the year kansas
city 69 and 83.